o corpo só usa mais um vídeo e hoje vou
ensinar como fazer é cuidar do garoto
que vocês tanto pediram para fazer ela
mostrar duas folhas a4 emissora quiser
eu vou usar professora
vocês podem usar papel quadriculado de
linhas de design
o importante é que faz o tamanho a4 e só
uma coisa vocês não tiram dela contra
ninguém porque apesar de ser papel eu
conto muito com figo deve sustentar ou
não deve poder alojar ser e mental e é
tão só aos seus responsáveis e nunca
encontra ninguém então por o tutorial
passo a passo
[Música]
e para os alvos perto do estado
facilitaram mesmo esse passo a minha voz
favorito e se inscreva no canal isto
ajuda bastante na divulgação a evolução
do meu trabalho e claro que tiverem mais
sugestões do project podem deixar os
comentários que costumo fazer com vocês
viram a e pronto eis obrigado destino um
grande abraço e até a próxima de auê